[Musik]
euch darf ich zehn von zehn vergeben
hmm oh lecker sehr lecker innen sehr
Fasching muss ich sagen
[Musik]
hallo zusammen jeder spricht von pumpkin
Spies und überall sieht man nur noch
Pumpkins weiß und ich habe gedacht ich
mache heute ein Video in dem wir pumpkin
Spice einfach selber machen kurz erkläre
ich euch was es überhaupt ist also es
ist ein Gewürz eigentlich für
Kürbisrezepte aber eigentlich auch nicht
weil es schon lange nicht mehr so ist es
kommt aus Amerika wie irgendwie gefühlt
alles und ich war ja selber in New York
und das war wirklich es war genau dieser
Umschwung von Spätsommer auf Herz und
überall haben die Leute ihre Pumpkins
Spice ja Varianten rausgeholt und man
macht das auch nicht nur in den
typischen Pumpkin Pie dafür gibt es auch
ein Rezept hier wenn Sarah das
einarbeitet irgendwie verlinkt und ja
mittlerweile macht man das einfach auch
ein Getränke oder in Muffins in Cupcakes
in allen möglich Gebäcken und Getränken
und ja dafür brauchen wir einfach nur
fünf Gewürze die wir jetzt
zusammenrühren also angewürzen habe ich
hier Zimt Ingwer alles gemahlen übrigens
Nelke und Piment und Muskatnuss an sich
die Gewürze sind jetzt vielleicht nicht
so geheizt aber wenn ihr die zusammen
verrührt ergibt das eine wirklich
leckere Mischung und ich war anfangs ich
weiß noch letztes Jahr war ich gar nicht
so der pumpkin Spice Fan und irgendwann
habe ich mir dann auch diese typischen
Getränke gekauft ganz bekannt wurde dass
er jetzt durch Starbucks eigentlich
schon seit Jahrzehnten und die brauchten
einfach nur marketingtechnisch irgendwas
im Herbst irgendwas Neues auf die Karte
irgendwas limitiertes und dann haben die
damit angefangen und so hat sich das
einfach voll etabliert und ist auch
jetzt mittlerweile in Deutschland gut
rüber geschwappt und ich muss sagen in
Deutschland bietet das nicht Gebieten
gar nicht viele kaffeeser nur die coolen
vielleicht auch das Kikis kitchen coffee
nein wir haben auch richtig coole
pumpkin Spice Varianten bei uns im Café
und ich habe gerade heute zeige ich euch
einfach mal wie es selber macht das ist
jetzt sogar schon fertig und auch sehr
viel viel günstiger und gleich gibt es
auch noch drei Rezepte hier mit
allerdings ohne Kürbis weil nicht jeder
ist kürbisfan und trotzdem kann man
dieses kürbisgewürz eben benutzen so
jetzt haben wir uns mal ausgerechnet was
das kostet aber erstmal hole ich euch
das fertige Pulver also man sieht auch
schon an der Farbe und das ist einfach
richtig intensiv das ist ein bisschen
heller vom Geruch her schreibe ich
übrigens alle ganz genau
teelöffelangaben in die Infobox wie
immer
irgendein Gewürz kommt hier extrem durch
ich glaube es ist Piment was auch noch
dran gerochen doch Nelken wir hatten ja
gerade Wert vorhin noch mal an Nelken
pur gerochen doch es sind Nelken bei uns
kommt aber eher so Zimt aber so vom
Gefühl her alles so bis alles trinkt so
ein bisschen durch das ist so voll der
Mischmasch und hier sind es wirklich nur
die Nelken ja und ansonsten könnt ihr
jetzt mal das Video kurz stoppen und in
die Kommentare schreiben wenn ihr wisst
dass das hier 95 Cent kostet auch in der
Menge was habt ihr was glaubt ihr was
jetzt die Menge kostet schreibt es mal
in die Kommentare aber nicht mogeln
macht wirklich Pause und jetzt sind die
Auflösung dass hier kostet 86 Cent also
das ist in der Menge schon günstiger
viel viel günstiger als diese Menge das
finde ich so krass weil das so schnell
ging auch und vor allem hält sich das
jetzt auch mindestens ein Jahr einfach
in den Schraubglas reintun undicht
verschließen im Schrank Lagern übrigens
sind es ja auch alles Gewürze die man zu
Hause hat zum Kochen zum Backen und wenn
ihr gar nicht so viel braucht weil es
ist schon viel könnt ihr das ganze auch
halbieren und habt ihr auch noch den
Rest der Gewürze übrig für eure
Kochrezepte und Backrezepte alle Rezepte
die ich jetzt mache sind übrigens mega
gut Frühstücks geeignet jetzt machen wir
erstmal Hafer pumpkin Kekse pumpkin
Spice Kekse weil panchen wird ja
bedeuten das Kürbis mit drin ist aber
wie gesagt ich wollte heute einfach kein
Kürbis mit rein nehmen und die könnt ihr
ganz gut als mehlprepp vorbereiten also
wenn ihr morgens keine Zeit habt einfach
mal ein Keks frühstücken warum auch
nicht und da kommt das Zimmer warme
Butter rein ich schreibe euch wie immer
alle ganz genau Mengenangaben unten in
die Infobox da kommt jetzt noch brauner
Zucker mit dazu der schmeckt schon
karamellig und wenn ihr mögt auch schon
das Vanilleextrakt das ganze dann zwei
bis drei Minuten lang schön hell cremig
rühren und dann die trockenen Zutaten
schon mal verrühren
[Musik]
so jetzt schlage ich nur noch das Ei
rein lasse es so lange rühren bis sich
das gerade so verbindet dann kommen die
trockenen Zutaten mit dazu die habe ich
vorab miteinander verrührt und natürlich
auch unsere kernigen Haferflocken und
das auch nur noch ganz kurz unterrühren
zarte Haferflocken sind keine kernigen
aber wie gesagt ich schreibe euch alles
ganz genau in die Infobox
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch ganz spontan
Schokodrops reingegeben wir können
natürlich auch Trockenfrüchte nehmen
oder sie ganz weglassen und jetzt kommen
schon mal die kleinen Kügelchen ich
nehme einfach den Teig Portionierer auf
mein Backpapier mit Backblech Backpapier
mit Backblech mein Backpapier mit
Backblech
ja ist so normal man backt ja immer
Backpapier mit Backblech oder machst du
das anders zu Hause einmal aufs Blech
und dann für eine Stunde in den
Kühlschrank da müssen wir ein bisschen
geduldig sein und dann kommen sie jetzt
in den Backofen wenn ihr fragt warum
wofür braucht man jetzt diese Kühlzeit
damit Sie einfach im Ofen nicht
auseinander laufen die Butter wird dann
schön hart und fest und dann bleibt es
so ein bisschen in shape es wird aber
auf jeden Fall ein bisschen auseinander
laufen daher auch ein bisschen Platz
lassen zwischen den Keksen
während der Kühlzeit nutzen wir die Zeit
und machen Rezept Nummer 2 und das sind
eigentlich sogar auch zwei Rezepte weil
wir machen einmal Eis Pumpkins Spice
Latte und einmal den heißen pumpkin
Spice ich starte mal mit dem heißen ich
habe vorab Schlagsahne die muss ganz
kalt sein einfach steif geschlagen mit
ein bisschen Sahnefest und Vanille
Extrakt und das würde ich mir jetzt mein
Spritzbeutel wenn euch das zu
kompliziert ist nimmt einfach fertige
Sprühsahne allerdings hält sich das so
auch fertig bis zu drei Tage im
Kühlschrank das heißt ihr könnt den
Spritzbeutel einfach in den Kühlschrank
legen und dann immer wieder rausnehmen
und das ganze dann aufstützen so für den
heißen pumpkin Spice Latte einfach die
Milch erhitzen das habe ich gerade in
der Mikrowelle gemacht ich gebe das
jetzt direkt in mein Glas Achtung mit
den nehme jetzt gleich den
Milchaufschäumer also nicht so voll
machen kommt er gleich noch ordentlich
Schaum und noch zwei Espressi rein oder
einespresso falls es euch zu stark ist
so bevor ihr aufschlagt am besten schon
mal das pumpkin Spice damit reingeben
damit sich das auch darin schön
verbinden kann und ein bisschen frei
verrührt wird so und jetzt einfach rein
es sollte jetzt schon sehr schnell
schäumen ich warte sehen nicht so auf
die Lieferung von diese Milchaufschäumen
weil das ist der Wahnsinn und guckt ich
habe schon richtig viel Volumen ich muss
schon aufpassen dass es nicht ja
umsonst und gleich darfst du Taste
testen haben sie
Spice was denkst du denn denkst du
direkt an Herford
so und jetzt passiert Magic ihr könnt
übrigens hier auch wenn ihr mögt noch
Vanilleextrakt reingeben oder halt Sirup
für die süße ich lasse es jetzt aber
erstmal so vielleicht kommt ja noch
Sahne dazu
jetzt guckt euch den Schaum an was sieht
schon sehr lecker aus das sieht schon
sehr lecker aus und jetzt toppen wir
noch mit Sahne und dann muss ich mich
beeilen für ja schöne Fotos haben dass
ich du kannst direkt hier wir müssen uns
auch dann gleich beeilen mit den
endzehen dass die Sahne nicht absinkt
schon aber das könnte ja auch das sieht
ja auch irgendwie lecker aus oder wir
reden uns jetzt alles schön kommt noch
ein bisschen Gewürz oben drauf und dann
machen wir jetzt den Eis pumpkin Latte
[Musik]
so hier habe ich auch in die kalte Milch
unser pumpkin Spice reingegeben und
einfach kurz gemixt und dann kommt es
einfach auf die Eiswürfel
da dürfte auch ruhig voller machen denn
jetzt kommt noch Espresso und Topf und
dann könnt ihr euch das sofort gönnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
haben sie jetzt darfst du probieren
übrigens kleiner Tipp wenn ihr die Sahne
einfach massiger drauf spritzt dann hält
es auch das war sehr sparsam
also es ist draußen jetzt 20 Grad ich
will das kalt haben habe ungewohnt zu
trinken ich finde es mega lecker ich
mochte pumpkin Spice Getränke nicht ich
glaube du bist nicht so der Fan davon
ich bin nicht so der Pferde aber das
kann man sich geben auf jeden Fall nicht
auch finde ich sogar sehr also ich finde
ich war richtig dagegen letztes Jahr
noch als wir das bestellt hatten und
dann habe ich immer wieder bestellt bis
ich mochte Geschmäcker
besonders Rezept dazu stimmt und lecker
so an sich auch wenn meine Mutter macht
manchmal so warm und wie Kartoffeln
kochen Wasser warm da aber was ich liebe
ist die Kürbissuppe oh die ist geil oh
die ist lecker das ist auch sehr sehr
lecker
heute krass hätte ich nicht gedacht okay
ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt wieder
über zum nächsten Rezept unsere Cookies
sind nämlich gut ausgekühlt und die
werden jetzt gebacken also gibt es noch
ein Rezept drei Rezepte
aber ich bin gleich weg ich bin dafür
dass ich das dass ich den Test später
mache mit der handykam einfach ich will
trotzdem probieren okay wir machen jetzt
Rezept Nummer drei während die Cookies
jetzt backen anschließend das lasse ich
sie auch noch abkühlen und wir machen
jetzt French Toast mit pumpkin Spice und
French Toast ist ja früher mein
Lieblingsfrühstück gewesen ich habe so
geliebt und es ist auch super einfach da
gibt einfach Milch zusammen mit Eiern
einfach in eine große Schüssel und jetzt
kommt drauf an wo ihr euer pumpkin
Hinweis integriert entweder hier schon
mit drin es könnte sein dass ich das
nicht so gut auflöst findet ihr auch
wieder den elektrischen Milchaufschäumer
nehmen oder was ich auch viel cooler
finde ist gleich zusammen mit Butter und
Zucker einfach in der in die Pfanne mit
reingeben und wenn ihr sehr sendet könnt
ihr das am Ende auch noch mal oben
drüber streuen
[Musik]
es gibt nur ein paar Kleinigkeiten zu
beachten Butter sollte jetzt nicht zu
heiß erhitzt werden sonst verbrennt sie
und ihr könnt jetzt immer wieder für
arbeiten also wirklich immer nur so ein
kleines Stückchen Butter ich gehe auch
mit der Hitze immer wieder runter damit
sie eben nicht verbrennt Zucker reintun
einfach nach Gefühl so ein bisschen in
die Pfanne die karamellisiert dann noch
mal schön und dann auch hier wie gesagt
einfach pumpkin Spice reingeben gut
verrühren und dann geht es halt darum
dass man die Toastbrote wirklich zwei
drei mal hier in dieser Eiermischung
Welt damit er auch genug dran kleben
bleibt und dann von beiden Seiten schon
so hier seitlich wird sein vier Minuten
ungefähr
ja so ein bisschen anbraten und dann
könnt ihr das ganze Servieren mit
Ahornsirup mit der geschlagenen Sahne
oder einfach auch wie gesagt noch ein
bisschen Pumpkins weiß drüber geben
[Musik]
für ganz alleine hansa hat mich auf
jeden Fall heute richtig im Stich
gelassen
[Musik]
aber ich bin ja auch eine gute
testtesterin und ich probiere jetzt ich
habe noch ein bisschen trince-sauce
drauf briseln lassen draufdriseln lassen
mal ich finde da passt ja auch wie
gesagt Ahornsirup ganz gut aber den hat
jetzt nicht da und irgendwie dachte mir
so Karamell ist bestimmt auch richtig
lecker
darf ich zehn von zehn vergeben das ist
so lecker ich mag sie natürlich warm am
liebsten und sind sie noch lauwarm auch
sehr lecker und ich finde es schmeckt
Ruhe nach Herbst Winter bisschen
Richtung Weihnachten also schon es ist
schon echt nicht ich gebe zehn von zehn
und das sind auch so Rezepte von denen
man gar nicht denkt dass sie so lecker
sind man denkt sich so ja gönnt man sich
mal aber ich würde mir das glaube ich
wirklich öfter machen im Herbst also
unbedingt nachmachen und wir machen
jetzt weiter mit den Cookies meine Kekse
konnten jetzt bei 180 Grad Ober- und
Unterhitze im vorgeheizten Backofen 16
Minuten backen dadurch dass wir sie
gekühlt haben sind das halt richtig
schöne runde Cookies geworden und sie
halten sich luftdicht verpackt bis zu
vier Tage ihr könnt sie aber auch
einfrieren und dann halt immer wieder
nach Bedarf auftauen und essen
[Musik]
ich muss sagen ich mag meinen Job
einfach backen und probieren gibt doch
nichts geiles oder schön knackig draußen
oh lecker sehr lecker innen sehr fatschi
muss ich sagen und außen hat man ganz
leicht diesen Crunch und ich kann mir
das richtig vorstellen morgens wenn ich
keine Zeit habe und auf dem Sprung bin
gönne ich mir einfach so ein Müsli Keks
ein haferkeks richtig geil Leute ich
würde sagen macht's gerne nach wenn ihr
euch mehr solcher Rezepte wünscht wo vor
allem drei oder in dem Fall sogar vier
Rezepte in einem Video sind schreibt mir
das gerne in die Kommentare wir freuen
uns sehr über euer Feedback und
ansonsten macht euch noch einen
wunderschönen Sonntag und hinterlasst
mir wie gesagt gerne einen Kommentar bis
bald tschüss
Krümeln wir uns da am Werk
was haben wir denn hier was haben wir
denn hier leckeres fatschi Cookies
mega
die schmeckt noch mega gesund ohne Spaß
ohne Spaß ich finde die mega ist voll
gesund denn diese gesunden Kekse die man
so ein Supermarkt kauft die aber
eigentlich voller Zucker sind ich weiß
nicht wie viel Zucker ist aber schmeckt
nicht viel raus ich weiß nicht ich denke
schon dass der Zucker drin aber ich muss
sagen das schmeckt jetzt nicht so krass
süß falsch ja hat seine aber gut
[Musik]